there is a conference center in downtown
orlando this weekend
where donald trump still rules america
he might have lost the election
but not the faith of his party all my
friends still want trump things and
actually
uh the hat that i need i got the one
that says 20 20 on it but i need the one
that says 2024 on it
we're ready for president trump to come
back we want to see our president
and i say our president meaning the
people's president
trump the florida local will speak here
on sunday
his first public appearance since
leaving the white house banned from
twitter still
he's bound to have a lot to say i think
he wants to say the things
that will make twitter the most anxious
with him
uh which is maybe settling some scores
and taking people on who have said some
rather unkind things to him
but by the same token um i think he's
going to talk about
this coalition that he built i mean it's
a coalition unlike the republican
party's ever seen before
you would like donald trump to run again
in 24 would you oh absolutely absolutely
i think pretty much everybody here does
do you think he will i'm hoping so i
think what he's going to do though is i
don't think he'll commit tomorrow
if you've read his book the art of the
deal he likes to keep options open
typically political parties reinvent
themselves after an election loss
not the republicans if anything nothing
has changed
they believe in trump and want more of
the same no doubt who the star
attraction is here
and there's no doubt who they want to
run in 2024 but
what is interesting is not just who is
here but who is not here
big figures within the republican party
like mitt romney
like the former u.s vice president mike
pence
the former u.s ambassador the united
nations nikki haley
all of them have their own ambitions and
any of them
could be influential come 2024.
if a week is a long time in politics
then four years
is a lifetime but if donald trump wants
to run again
right now there doesn't seem to be much
to stop him
alistair uncle sky news orlando